bonsoir avoue david capitan merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france de
deux faits majeurs à retenir à l'issue
de cette journée de scrutin pour les
élections fédérales en allemagne c'est
le spd
qui est en forte hausse et un la cd ou
qui en caisse un revers on va dire
historique et puis maintenant on a un
bras de fer qui est qui s'annonce en vue
d'éventuelles tractations pour succéder
à angela merkel
absolument la situation est celle que
vous venez de décrire il faut savoir que
pour le choix des électeurs envers un
nouveau gouvernement allemand en réalité
ne savent à la première étape c'était
que ce qui a été choisie aujourd'hui
c'était un nouveau parlement et c'est à
ce parlement au parti qui l'animent qui
appartiendra à travers le choix d'une
coalition de déterminer qui sera le
successeur dans gala merkel qui sera le
prochain chancelier donc lorsque nous
avons aujourd'hui en réalité celle
équilibre entre les partis politiques et
la première remarque que je voudrais
faire c'est que au delà de deux des
rapports respectifs entre les deux gros
partis que sont le parti socialiste le
spd et puis le parti démocrate chrétien
qui est lassé d où il faut noter la nabe
est tout de même importante du parti
d'extrême droite de la fdc ta dire que
contrairement à la france est bien la
remise en cause de l'hégémonie des deux
grands partis traditionnels ses portes
et non pas vers des partis populistes ni
vers l'extrême gauche ni vers l'extrême
droite qui encore une fois a subi un
sérieux revers par rapport aux dernières
élections de 2017 ce sont en réalité
deux nouveaux partis les verts les
libéraux à des partis donc rationnelle
des partis démocratiques qui ont tout de
même emporté la mise c'est donc un
polissage renouvelée et un paysage qui
même relativement classique auquel on
aura affaire en allemagne
la fdr le parti très adroite en
allemagne donc qu'ils avaient
dont l'entrée justement au bout des
seins en 2017 c'était un fait marquant
on s'en souvient mais on pensait aussi
que ces élections allaient
sceller à l'enracinement de l'afd dans
le paysage politique allemand ce n'est
pas du tout le cas ce que vous dites ça
absolument on s'était vraiment ce qui
est intéressant nous sommes en france
vous savez avec des élections qui ont vu
l extrême droite prendra un rôle un peu
de de contestation regroupés à travers
les mouvements qui se sont succédé de
crise en france est bien certain nombre
de lectorat on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui de la candidature de
monsieur émaux l'extrême droite est tout
de même très en avance dans le paysage
français en allemagne et bien on a une
réaction contraire au contraire ce sont
les partis démocratiques les parties
parlementariste qui se trouve un petit
peu à l'honneur alors évidemment la
question qui reste aujourd'hui
déterminante est de savoir quels seront
les et coalitions qui pourront se former
dans le futur votre reportage l'a dit
tout à l'heure on s'oriente à priori
plutôt vers une solution à trois partis
car en effet le spd et la cd ou les
chrétiens-démocrates et les sociaux
démocrates malgré la remontée des
sociaux-démocrates ont tout de même une
force relative qui est relativement
basse de sorte qu'ils ne pourront pas
fonctionner un de ces deux partis avec
un parti d'appoint que pourraient être
les verts ou le fdp il faut cette fois à
priori se tourner vers une solution à
trois parties la troisième position à
trois parties se seraient le spd l'a
cédée ou et les verts on a entendu tout
à l'heure à anna lena a bear box exprimé
son parti donc qui arrive en troisième
position ce sera logique oui alors il ya
deux solutions à trois parties qui se
propose il faudra en tout état de cause
le fdp donc les libéraux et les verts et
qui ensuite ceux ci pourront décider
d'appuyer soit le spd avec une coalition
qui serait en outre situées plus à
gauche ou alors au contraire décidé de
se réunir sous la bannière de l'union et
d'armes ils l'achètent avec une
coalition qui sera un peu plus à droite
ce cas mon avis ne faut pas non plus
écarter complètement c'est le
renouvellement d'une grande coalition
comme celle que nous avons connue depuis
plusieurs années en allemagne c'est à
dire un remboursement des deux partis le
parti social démocrate et le parti
chrétien démocrate
il est vrai qu'à l'origine de cette
campagne électorale est bien le spd
avait dit qu'il ne voulait absolument
pas d'une grande coalition parce que
celle ci lui avait nui cas présent dans
les résultats des dernières élections
mais comme vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure cette élection là c'est marqué
par une grande remontée du spd et
peut-être que celui ci serait moins
réticents au regard de cette évolution à
ce qu'une grande coalition puisse être
formée
trois possibilités c'est vrai quand on
parlait de ce bras de fer qui s'annonce
à l'issue donc du scrutin on va attendre
évidemment elle est le verdict définitif
des urnes mais donc ce sont de longues
tractations qui vont qui vont débuter
est-ce qu'il ya le risque quand même le
spd et la cdu ou qui ont ils disent
vouloir une future coalition avant noël
est-ce qu'il ya quand même le risque de
voir s'installer mimicry en allemagne
même si c'est vrai la chancelière va
assurer de toute façon le la gouvernance
oui la mini crise qu'il faut relativiser
les choses en 2017 on a mis six mois à
peu près pour réussir à constituer une
coalition à ce que la chancellière
angela merkel retrouve le poste qu'elle
avait déjà ailleurs auparavant donc
c'est une crise qui en réalité n'en est
pas une dans le paysage allemand puisque
en effet ces négociations à partir du
parlement font partie entièrement du
mécanisme du gouvernement allemand pour
arriver à une coalition je crois que ce
qui va être le plus compliqué c'est
d'arriver à se faire entendre le les
libéraux d'une part et les verts d'autre
part ensuite on verra si c'est avec le
spd ou avec l'accepter ou quelque chose
doivent se faire mais plutôt par les
petits partis puis à mon sens il faut
commencer à réfléchir et pour arriver à
un équilibre entre ces deux partis qui
se sont beaucoup combattu pendant la
campagne le parti vert et le parti fdp
qui sont les deux parties un peu nouveau
le fdp très anciens qui ont connu un
grand développement de cette campagne au
détriment du spd et de la 2cv ou
évidemment chacun d'entre eux essayé de
tirer les marrons du e et ça les a
conduits à s'opposer de manière
importante quand la campagne doit
arriver aujourd'hui à trouver un accord
entre eux sinon ce sera de nouveau la
grande coalition qui sera la porte de
sortie n'oubliez pas qu'en 2017 à la
merkel à la 2 cv ou avait commencé à
discuter justement avec les raies et le
fdp et finalement ce première tentative
de qualys pour a échoué et c'est alors
qu'elle a finalement décidé de se
tourner vers des partenaires
le spd
partenaires et opposants pour constituer
une grande coalition
alors dans quel délai puisque vous
parliez de crise c'est évidemment un
petit peu de dire dans quelle des
lettres seront cela dépend du temps que
mettront les parties à trouver un accord
il faut noter que le spd a fait un temps
laissé ouverte la possibilité de
constituer une coalition qu'on appelait
une coalition rouge rouge verte c'est à
dire de garder les verts comme
partenaire de choisir comme autres
partenaires l'extrême gauche en réalité
aujourd'hui secteur coton est écartée
puisque en effet l'extrême gauche très
mauvais résultat au tour 2 % elle est
même pas sûr d'avoir les 5% qui lui
permettront d'arriver au parlement
j'espère conclure pour conclure la
décapitant le taux de participation
on s'attendait à un taux de
participation assez élevé il ya aussi
les votes postaux qui vont peser lourd
sur cette journée de scrutin on le sait
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus
alors le lieu effectivement les
résultats que nous avons actuellement ne
permettent pas de trancher complètement
les résultats car en effet comme vous
l'avez dit ce sont 40 %
d'électeurs qui ont voté par
correspondance en amont de l'élection il
faut dire aussi que le système électoral
allemand est un peu compliqué parce
qu'en effet chaque électeur donne deux
votes un vote pour un député dans sa
circonscription et l'autre pour un parti
politique ne sorte que tout ça est assez
compliqué à dépouiller il faudra donc
attendre les heures qui viennent pour
savoir vers quelle coalition on peut
imaginer de deux de se tourner mais
encore une fois les choses sont
suffisamment complexe dans le parlement
actuel pour que peut-être les choses m
quelques mois se décanter l'agacement
évidemment sera pour nous pour l'europe
de savoir repérer la gohelle exemple
l'autre question nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler
oui merci beaucoup à vous david capitons
pour votre analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes président de l'université franco
allemande